August 16 2014 a drone capturing images
in MO Co Northwest Mexico reveals
shocking footage of a crack in the earth
that seems to have appeared overnight
the earth is literally ripped itself
upon 16 feet wide and 25 feet deep the
gaping chasm has devastated everything
in its path including farmland and the
link road to highway 26 a vital artery
which connects an MoU CEO to the rest of
Mexico
I think the crack near air Maceo Mexico
is sort of shocking in its abruptness
you've got the desert landscape and then
all of a sudden very crisp clean walls
and a deep fissure into the earth it's
kind of weird the crack of that
magnitude indicates that something is
moving in the earth on a rather large
scale geologists at the nearby
University of Sonora theorized that the
terrifying crack could have been created
by vast quantities of water being sucked
out of the ground leaving the surface to
crack apart one of the first things
geologists think of when they hear about
holes or cracks opening up is is
groundwater in the agricultural industry
they rely on groundwater to to water
their plants and essentially what they
do is they drill holes into the ground
and they suck the water out in this arid
landscape farmers need a vast amount of
water to irrigate all their crops they
extract water from below the earth's
surface which could inadvertently lower
the water table and create cracks where
the land is dried out
could groundwater have dropped or been
removed the place where that water was
collapses it leaves some kind of a void
and that can very frequently result in
cracks NASA scientists have recently
warned that the problem might not be
confined to Mexico
widespread groundwater losses could
create a wave of similar collapses all
over the world you don't need to
completely remove the groundwater for
the ground to subside and in fact we saw
at the bottom of the crack that there
was a stream of water flowing you only
need to remove some of the groundwater
for substance to occur if this monstrous
crack truly is caused by extreme
agriculture the disturbance won't go
away anytime soon and the crack is
getting white
you